hello and welcome to a week six edition
of the Beacher report fantasy football
show presented by State Farm my name is
Adam Levitan establish the run.com as
always joined by Michael Leone of
establish the run.com to talk about some
players that maybe were lower on this
week than we would normally be due to
various reasons Leone how's it going
today it's going pretty well you know
hoping my Buffalo Bills bounce back this
week from a tough one last week but
otherwise going well
good uh before we get into some of the
Fades that we're on for this week just
wanted to take two quick questions from
chat as people file in from GG Jackson
he says Tony Pard or Travis etn this
week man how can you not be starting
both Pard and etn here uh sir uh you
must have an extremely loaded team I'd
be hard pressed to sit Tony Pard this
week against the Chargers I think it's
an awesome awesome awesome breakout spot
for Tony Pard but yeah I'd obviously be
trying to start both of them Travis etn
has a fine matchup as well home against
the Colts anything you have straight up
Leone on Pard vers
etn yeah I think it's Pard um Dallas is
just you know their team total is high
it's a really uptempo game his
opportunities have been awesome so um
definitely sticking with the priors from
from the beginning of the Season Johnny
Wallace says Jerry Judy Christian Kirk
or Tyler Lockett in the flex this week
Jerry Judy Christian Kirk or Tyler
Lockett in the flex now I'll say this
about Christian Kirk there is a culdesac
narrative going on I'm not sure if you
guys are aware Christian Kirk Trevor
Lawrence and Doug Peterson all live in
the same neighborhood allegedly in the
same culdesac in said neighborhood
that's got to lead to more targets for
Christian Kirk and we've seen that over
the last three to four weeks man the guy
is getting absolutely Fed so yeah Leon
what do you think about that one Judy
Lockett or Christian Kirk I think Judy's
the odd man out here and it's between
Kirk and Lockett only concern with Kirk
is in this matchup you know out of the
gate week one for Jacksonville when Z
Jones was healthy we saw Jacksonville
run the ball a lot more didn't play a
lot of three wide receiver sets which
led to you know Kirk's worst game of the
season I think it'll be better this time
around it's one of our favorite uptempo
games um so really I think it's a coin
flip between Kirk and Lockett all yeah I
think Kirk I mean I think Z Jones might
miss this game again too k z Jones
dealing with a knee injury right now
also all right let's get into some of
the fades in other words these are guys
that we think will underperform this
week relative to maybe their Baseline
expectation for V season doesn't mean
that you have to sit them on your season
long team but these are guys that maybe
I personally or leody personally would
not want to play in DFS this week if
they were at their normal ownership
we'll start with Derek
Henry bad signs for Derrick Henry lately
Leone because I mean even last week they
were in a neutral script the entire game
the game was very close with the Colts
and taji Spears still played a ton you
know I thought in close games in years
past that was a spot Derrick H would get
25 touches instead taji Spears stepped
up and got 14 I believe it was 12
opportunities of his own now they go to
London for a difficult matchup I think
against the Ravens here so yeah I think
Derrick Henry like if I had derck Henry
in season long I wouldn't be sitting him
per se but I would certainly be lowering
my expectations any thoughts on Derrick
Henry's spot here against the Ravens
Le yeah I mean the Ravens are allowing
just 3.6 yards per carry in this one
Baltimore is favored um by Four Points
so I do think it's a pretty bad spot for
Derrick Henry it's you know hard in a
season long to fully sit him but he's
going to be a lot more volatile than in
the past a lot more game script
dependent he was always someone we said
was gam script dependent it wasn't
really because they fed him no matter
what and he he broke so many big plays
but I think in today's uh game this year
he is truly gam script dependent so I'm
definitely worried about the floor here
all right yeah if you guys are in season
long League I think you should check to
see if taji Spears is on your wire
because taji Spears is a guy you might
be able to start and a pinch if you
needed to but also something happened to
Derrick Henry pretty nice setup for taji
Spears second fade is Debo Samuel now
interesting spot here for Debo Samuel B
banged UPA played last week Brown's
defense is no joke I mean Browns defense
49ers defense Cowboys I there's a lot of
really good defenses in the NFL it has
been a struggle for teams to do much
against the Browns now 49ers offense is
so so so efficient maybe it doesn't
matter not expect them to have DeShaun
Watson here which I think is worse for
Debo Samuel in other words less likely
that we'll see more pass attempts from
BR Brock pie than usual here against the
Browns what do you think about Debo and
auk in my mind I'd say Leone auk is
separating from Debo in this offense
where auk is just a better Flatout wide
receiver route Runner gets open easier
than Debo
does yeah we are seeing iuk separate I
think we have him for a higher Target
share at this point didn't you know
think that was going to be the case
prior to the year starting we have had
Debo banged up for a couple weeks so
we'll sort of see where that settles but
ultimately the hard part with this San
Francisco passing game is just the
volume you know the efficiency is going
to be there but now you've got them as
you said a really good defense in
Cleveland it looks like the weather is
going to be a problem this game I'm kind
of surprised the team total for San
Francisco is only 23 despite the fact
that we're not expecting deshun Watson
to start right now so it just looks like
a gross game so I think Debo's gonna be
fine he can always break break a big
play they use him in a variety of ways
but it just for the whole passing game
in general this isn't the best spot to
attack San Francisco agreed San
Francisco is going to have a ton of good
good good spots this is not one of them
third fate is a guy that you
know I don't want to give up on Devonte
Smith you know he had one bad game he
had one airball here we've seen Dallas
Gard have three four bad games and then
break out we've seen AJ Brown get the
squeaky wheel I don't think it's crazy
to think Devonte Smith will eventually
get the squeaky wheel here for the
Eagles and start to get fed more
remember last year targets between AJ
Brown and Devonte Smith were roughly
equal this year Devonte Smith has been a
good tier behind AJ Brown in terms of
earning targets I don't know how sticky
that will be but regardless when you
play the Jets it's really hard to throw
the football I mean this is an awesome
awesome awesome secondary that the Jets
have it's way easier to run the ball on
the Jets and so I I don't want to give
up on Devonte Smith I just don't think
this is the spot for him to break out
what do you think about eagles pass game
and Devonte Smith this week against the
Jets yeah I mean in some ways it's
similar to the San Francisco thing like
we want to be in on teams that are going
to score a lot of points against Bad
teams but sometimes the way the matchup
aligns the Eagles aren't going to have
to press it most likely against Zach
Wilson and to your point if they can
choose which way to attack the Jets
defense they're going to choose the
ground game the Jets are allowing 4.5
yards per carry that's bottom 10 in the
NFL and we know with the Eagles
offensive line like they they can they
can push Swift down the field and and
get some big chunks that
way all right let's put a pause here on
our Fades and take some questions from
our good friends in the chat from CCI
Rhino says CJ Stroud or Dak Prescott
this week I mean if you would have said
that to me before the season I would be
like oh my God are you are you crazy but
Dak has been struggling we can't deny
that and stoud has been shredding now I
do think this is an awesome get right
spot for the Cowboys they go to the
Chargers and the Kell Mo Bowl they're
going to have to expand the offense I
think Dak can play well and can play way
way way better but yeah there's
questions about Dak right now for sure
on the other side CJ strad gets a home
game against the Saints which is no
great matchup in its own right Leon what
do you think about that one straight up
Dak or CJ
strad in this game environment you got
to go Dak Prescott I think Dallas
offense in general is a great by low for
the rest of the season really high total
tight spread Up Tempo uh it's absolutely
daak for me okay agreed uh from Laren
says Jonathan Taylor or Bree Hall this
week Jonathan Taylor or Bree Hall so the
big question is Zack Moss has played so
well how will the split go in week six
between Jonathan Taylor and Zach Moss my
my take is that you can't pay Jonathan
Taylor all that money and then just have
him on the sideline while Zach Moss
shreds right that just makes you look
like a bunch of fools so my take is like
55 60% of the running back touches to JT
here with maybe upside for more the rest
to Zach
moss on the other side Bree Hall we saw
get over 70% of the running back
opportunities for the Jets last week
which is an awesome breakout difficult
difficult spot though for Bree here
against the Eagles straight up Leone
Bree or Mr
JT it's really tough one the way we have
it projected at established run right
now is Bree Hall ahead but so much of
that is just dependent on how you break
down the split between JT and Moss which
we have split pretty evenly for this
week I think that's right for week two
and eventually it's going to go more
JT's way in which case I'd roll the dice
on Bree who did get the lon share of the
carries last week despite the bad
matchup and then we got another question
from Action Jackson about James Cook or
Zach moss in Flex so sticking with this
Indie backfield again with us you know
as good as Zach Moss has played I think
this a great spot for James Cook the
bills huge favorites at home against the
Giants without Daniel Jones their
offensive line is an absolute mess the
Giants offensive line and James Cook you
know had a couple rough games in a row
where the script just didn't go great
for him they couldn't run the ball last
week but they've shown more of an
ability and more of a want to run the
ball this year and this is the perfect
spot for him to be you know break some
big carries have a really high
efficiency game yeah I I agree mainly
because I'm worried that if you start
Zach Moss I mean it's not crazy to think
JT comes in and gets 70% of the running
back opportunities in this game like not
at all um they've also reduced Josh
Allen's designed runs I don't know if
you have a take on that Leon I know
we're going off script here but do you
have a take on why they've reduced Josh
Allen's designed runs there I'm only
asking because Leone is indeed a buffalo
laundry
bro yeah I think it's just to try and
keep him a bit healthier for the course
of this season yeah um Allen hasn't
shown the best intelligence in terms of
of not taking hits and avoiding hits so
this is one way to take that decision-
making off his plate they still do it
sometimes around the goal line and
whatnot but yeah it's absolutely reduced
from previous Seasons all right let's
jump into our bundles next fantasy
bundles presented by State Farm where
bundling your home and auto insurance is
just another way to save with the
personal price plan so bundles are just
some guys that we think work well
together this week if anyone plays DFS
that is kind of our specialty at
establish the run if you're playing DFS
and you're playing tournaments you
likely not always but likely want to be
stacking your quarterback with a pass
catcher these are some ideas that we had
as good ones this week we'll start with
Lamar Jackson going up with uh Z flowers
now they have this London game against
the Titans we've talked before Titans
are very good against the Run not very
good at defending the past Z flowers is
up towards an elite Target share I mean
we're talking 28 29% and he's starting
to see more targets down the field to me
Z flowers is the best wide receiver on
this team and it's not even close and I
think the Ravens already know it so yeah
flowers Lamar Jackson is one second one
Leone is Kirk Cousins and Jordan Addison
obviously when you play the Bears
everything is accentuated what do you
think about Addison without Justin
Jefferson
here yeah I'm really excited to see what
happens here I think he's going to get a
bigger relative boost with Jefferson out
than KJ Osborne is KJ Osborne was
already running you know almost all the
routes that he could handle whereas
Addison was around 65 70% routes I
believe and he's going to be 90% plus
most likely now with Jefferson out
higher targets guy more explosive player
which is why we had the first round
draft capital on him so I'm excited for
it and Chicago's defense you know it's a
limited sample to start the year but
similar to Tennessee you know they've
been getting beat a lot more in the air
giving up eight yards per pass attempt
as opposed to on the ground where
they're giving up just 3.7 you know
those respective ranks is 11th in run
defense in yards per carry but 31 and
pass defense and yards per pass
attempt third bundle presented by State
Farm of course is Trevor Lawrence to
Calvin Ridley I mean people are all over
the place on Calvin Ridley after week
one it was like oh my God I I have the
best wide receiver in fantasy and then
he had a couple bad games and it was oh
my God should I be dropping Calvin
Ridley the truth is obviously somewhere
in the middle I think I've been a little
bit disappointed that Calvin really
hasn't separated from guys like
Christian Kirk in terms of Target share
however he's had some horrific drops if
he didn't have those he would be looking
way way way better and in this spot
against the Jaguars just a really I
think game that has a chance to get into
a real back and forth game here with muu
back there for the Colts that is the
third bundle fourth one Leon is one we
just talked about Dak Prescott and cidd
lamb there's definitely a lot of CD lamb
people out out there that are probably
like one and four right now that are in
panic mode I actually like buying CD
lamb right now if you can before this
game what do you think about Dak and
cidi here against the
Chargers yeah I like a lot you know
continuing my Pro Dallas stuff here and
um and including Jacksonville like these
last two bundles we put together are the
two games that look like the fastest
Pace games of the week like if you look
at time to snap average play clock if
you look at no huddle rates it's the
Jacksonville indie game and the LA
Dallas game and there's just going to be
so many plays run with two quarterbacks
on each side they're gonna be pretty
efficient and this is the absolute
perfect spot to unleash Dak it's been
tough just because they've had a couple
of down games they had you know really
tough opponent in San Francisco they had
a couple games where they won in blowout
fashion but this is one that looks like
it's going to be a pretty good back and
forth and isn't too difficult of a
matchup in terms of opposing defense so
I think Dallas in general is great by
low opportunity rest of season and you
should absolutely be firing up Dak and
cidi this week last bundle goes to Miami
now obviously if I could I would play
Tua and Tyreek together every time but I
think the by low opportunity is actually
on Jaylen wad who out targeted Tyreek
last week actually had a touchdown
called back by penalty did Jaylen Wadd
they're playing Carolina here may be
able to do whatever they want against
Carolina
feels like a pretty good breakout spot
for Jaylen wad assuming that we don't
have Raheem moer and Tyreek kill out
there scoring 90 yard touchdowns on
every play because that's obviously not
good for anyone else on the team so yeah
Tua and wad all right let take a couple
questions from chat here Leon Gabe Leon
says Jerry Judy or Curtis Samuel in the
flex Jerry Judy tonight or Curtis Samuel
now Curtis Samuel has quietly earned a
15% Target share which isn't far off of
Terry mcen who's at 16% which shocked me
I thought that they would be much
tighter to doson and McClaren this
season not Curtis Samuel so this is
actually getting to be interesting Jerry
Judy or Curtis Samuel yeah I still think
I'm gonna go Judy on this one he's the
more talented player he's going to have
a higher Target share and they're going
to have a negative game script most
likely against Kansas City and be
throwing it a lot more whereas
Washington you got to temper somewhat
expectations they set a record in terms
of number of consecutive plays dropping
back to pass last week because they got
in such a Negative script this game
versus Atlanta you're not going to see
the same pass volume it could actually
be kind of a gross game The Way Atlanta
runs and it sort of encourages other
teams to run not that Washington's gonna
be bad but uh the team expectation would
need to be much higher for me to start
Samuel over Jerry
Judy from Jimmy tenson says Brock pie or
two at tug of ioa I mean
look I love Brock py but given the way
Tua is playing right now given the way
his weapons are I don't think you can
sit Tua for like almost anyone at this
point I mean Tua I love per but this is
not a great match up for him as we
already talked about and yeah Tua is
just better play
anyways all right let's get back into
our Fades here we have three left to get
to we'll start with uh Michael Thomas
here now Michael Thomas has been better
than I thought but you know who else has
been better than I thought Texans
everyone on the Texans and Texans
secondary and I think Chris who would a
little bit of a toe issue in pregame
last week expecting him to be full
strength here a bit of a squeaky wheel
after a bad game for him you get Alan
chimra back too which I think is not
great for Michael Thomas as we've seen
the last couple weeks so yeah I
understand that Michael Thomas is
playing well this is not the spot I
think for a big Michael Thomas game
though however Leon any thoughts on
Saints pass catchers here yeah I'm
probably a little bit more optimis Miss
got Michael Thomas than you are got him
ahead of you know Jerry Judy who's been
in a lot of start sit questions in our
projections this week he's been able to
hold on to the 90% plus route rate um
and in general the full PPR League you
know very high catch rate player if it's
half PPR you're looking at less
explosive plays it might be a bit more
down on him but I think also the way the
Texans are playing uptempo and willing
to throw the ball more than we expected
with CJ strad should have an overall
positive impact on the game environment
all
right next fade is in the game tonight
courland Sutton
so I think Chief's defense is actually
really good
like and momes hasn't been great the
wide receiv receivers has been terrible
but they're still winning games because
I think their defense is actually
awesome I expect courland St to see a
lot of larius Sneed tonight which is not
great for him on the perimeter Sneed is
very very good and yeah I I just think
overall it's a tough spot for courin
Sutton especially and really the entire
Broncos offense so I can see this game
turning into a shootout here but there
is wind in this game we're seeing
forecast up to 20 miles an hour for
those guys who aren't too familiar with
how weather works in the NFL we have a
ton of data on this rain doesn't really
matter that much even snow doesn't
matter that much only at the extremes of
cold and heat doesn't matter that much
one thing we know matters though sustain
wins in like the 1820 plus mph range is
bad and that's what is they are
projecting tonight so yeah a lot of
things stacking up against courand
Sutton here Leon any thoughts on him in
the game tonight yeah I would know too
it seems like Jerry Judy's finally
getting healthier he had his highest
route participation in the season last
week which led to a 23% Target share for
him and that pulled away from courland
suon who had just a 10% Target share you
get Greg dolage back it's possible at
some point Marvin Mims gets involved and
I just think there's a lot of downside
risk to Su in this week yeah for sure
all right last fade Sixth and Final Fade
is going to be Sam Howell now Sam Howell
had about 30 fantasy points last week
just went completely completely off as
Leon already talked about this Falcons
team can turn games ugly man I mean
they're going to try to have 30 35
40 running back carries like that's the
way they ideally want to play and they
want to hide Desmond Ritter obviously
when you're on the other side of that
it's not that great and so yeah you know
Sam Howell takes so many
sacks he needs these crazy trailing game
scripts I think to have any shot at 20
25 30 fantasy points I just think this
game will be closer throughout so yeah
probably out on Sam Howell here we
originally had deshun Watson as a fade
but now it looks like desan Watson is
not even going to play in this game so
for full clarity for full transparency
pulling back the curtain here on the
Bleacher Report fous football show Sam
how was the backup in this spot to
DeShaun Watson who's now not expected to
play but anyways Leon yeah any thoughts
on Sam how here I'm going think you now
that I think people are going to chase
last week's game looking at the fantasy
point total but you know Washington's a
great spot if you get him playing from
behind because they're willing to just
let how Chuck it but this just looks
like a low total game they're going to
have a higher run rate than usual
Atlanta's pass defense is solid too so
there's just not a lot here that I like
for
how agreed so our fade list for this
week is the big dog himself Derk Henry
Debo
Samuel Devonte Smith the slim
Reaper Michael Thomas can't guard Mike
courand Sutton and Sam
Howell all right we got uh time here for
for take some questions from chat let's
go to Zeus Zeus says should dvin cook be
kept on my roster I mean d played 10
snaps last
week and I think as long as Bree Hall
and Michael Carter stay healthy that's
the expectation even if Bree Hall didn't
stay healthy I'm not even sure i' want
to start dvin cook with Zach Wilson at
the quarterback I know DAV cook has a
big name I know he's been a great
fantasy player for a long time when
these Dusty veteran withered running
backs get released there is a massive
infatuation with them from seemingly
both the NFL and the fantasy community
that is just like so unwarranted there
is a reason that the Vikings let go of
dvin cook so yeah I think pretty easy
call to dump dvin cook there n77 says is
Brandon auk to land a decent game given
your call to fade Debo what do you think
about Brandon auk here in this spot
against the Browns Leone yeah I have
some con concerns with auk that are the
same with Debo where this just could be
an ugly game that San Francisco wins
somewhat easily and doesn't have to
throw very often um which we've seen
them do this year but they've just been
so efficient and auk's been so good that
like we have him ranked ahead of Debo
for the week and I kind of think you
have to start him just looking at the
range of outcomes with you know how well
he's performed with pie this season for
sure doski demand says Terry McClaren
Deo Samuel or KJ o
so yeah we haven't mentioned KJ Osborne
who will be flowing into that Justin
Jefferson role for the Vikings and oh by
the way the Vikings get to play the
Bears this week which massively inflates
KJ Osborne's projections so I get it on
that it would still be really hard for
me to pull the trigger on KJ Osborne who
I think is like a middling average maybe
sub average NFL talent for some of these
Elite guys what do you think about that
one leody McClaren Debo or KJ
Osborne I think I'm going Debo with that
one I know we had him as a fade we do
like guys like Tyler lock at DeAndre
Hopkins more than Debo this week but you
know as you said with the target share
in Washington not being as concentrated
as we expected think the P attempts fall
back and Osborne is sort of just a guy
that I don't want to promote too much
just because of the opportunity there
that I'm I'm just gonna go with the the
most talented player of the group here
and that's Deo C Wagman Says Z flowers
or Nico Collins this week so talks about
how I really like the spot for Z flowers
don't really like the spot for Nico
Collins here home game against the
Saints can't deny though that Nico's had
a great year what do you think about Z
flowers verse Nico Collins here in week
six man I think that's a really close
one with how well Nico's performed I'd
hate to bench him our projections do
lean Z flowers' way a little bit more um
in in b projection but our ceiling
favors Nico Collins because of the big
plays that we've seen from him because
of the higher touchdown rate we've seen
from him so hate to be a c you know to
cop out and say it's a coin flip but I
think it's a coin flip I might lean Z
flowers because I think there's a bit
more upside in the pass rate for
Baltimore than we're currently
projecting given the makeup of this
Tennessee defense yeah I like flowers I
like flowers there but I I would also
note that we are watching tank Dell's
injury tank Dell has a concussion I
don't know if he's going to get cleared
certainly can start projecting a few
more t niik Collins way if tank were to
get ruled out Ryder Sullivan says DJ
Moore or puka
Nika so DJ Moore is coming off of
massive back-to-back games now these two
games were in very very easy spots
commanders and Broncos but DJ Moore has
another easy spot this week against the
Vikings meanwhile Cooper cup Cooper cup
came back which wasn't great for puka
but it wasn't horrible either what do
you think about that one DJ Moore or
puka nakua
I I wish I didn't have to answer this
question because DJ Moore has already
made me look silly a bunch this year
because I've been sort of out on DJ
Moore I do think ultimately like he's
getting there because he's has like the
most yards per Target ever through five
games you know he has just an absolutely
insane start but a lot of the play
calling stuff with Chicago is not you
know really different than what we
expected which is going to be the lower
completion rate offense lower pass
volume look at puk's offense it's the
exact opposite you know you've got a
quarterback that's going to complete you
know a high percentage of passes he's a
pure pocket passer they're playing
really uptempo they're going to call
more passes than normal so even if you
think they get the same share of their
team's targets that's more fantasy
points for puka so puka is my my answer
here Chad Fletcher says Josh DS Garrett
Wilson or Tyler Lockett he needs two so
we need to bench one of these three now
Garrett Wilson is a so talented and
tough to bench I mean I would not be
benching Gary Wilson even with Zack
Wilson against these options so we need
to sit one Leone out of Josh DS or Tyler
Lockett I do think that Garner muu is a
little bit better for Josh DS than
Anthony Richardson of course Anthony
Richardson will miss this game with his
shoulder injury but Tyler Lockett is a
very good NFL player I think that I
would be starting Garrett Wilson and
Tyler locket any disagreement there
Leone no disagreement for me you know
Downs is someone I'm optimistic about
but it's still too early to start him
over proven players like that
n Steven n says Zack hers Cole KT or
Kyle pittz oh baby we got a huge Kyle
pits game last week seven catches 87
yards zero
touchdowns I mean zacher we're laughing
but zachar has no chance of seven for 87
none you know and and Co K probably
doesn't either now Co KT and zachar both
have way better bets for touchdowns but
yeah I mean I thought it was really
promising for Zach for k pittz now one
thing I'll say about Kyle Pitts from
last week the Falcons got down ended up
throwing a ton that is not what they
want to do in any like close game
winning game they're going they're not
going to have that many attempts for
Desmond Ritter so yeah Leon it's a tough
one here Zs Commander
pits I'm going with the dusty vet give
me Zack SS he carved out a pretty good
Target share here dos has been better
than expected you know I think it's a
you we've got some gross games this week
this is one of the higher total better
game envir
so yeah I'm going Dusty bet with Zack SZ
here it hurts me to say that as a Kyle
Pitt St but it's just so you know the
game last week was awesome but he's the
floor is so low right now with him not
completely healthy in the way that they
call plays anyways even when he is
completely healthy um generally I take
this ceiling of pits most weeks but I'm
I'm GNA lean s if it's full PPR if it's
like a standard League or half then then
I'll slide towards pits and and you know
accept the big play playability a bit
more even if it's riskier there there's
two ways you can start Kyle Pitts here I
think uh Stephen the first one is you
looked at your matchup and you're a dog
and you need some ceiling right and in
that case I might go you're a big dog I
might go pits the second way is if you
want to have fun if you don't want to
have fun then you can go Zack Herz if
you hate fun then you can go Zack Herz
if you like to have fun in life then you
can go Kyle pits last one here before we
get out of here from not Derwin James
shingly I didn't think I thought that
Derwin James might actually be in here
asking questions about his fous football
team but anyways Alexander Madison or
Deontay Foreman so two guys I think
going opposite directions Alexander
Madison I think is worse with Justin
Jefferson because he'll have fewer
touchdown
opportunities and also cam ACR was
eating in a little bit more than we'd
like last week to Alexander Madison on
the other end if Roshan Johnson's out in
this game Deontay Foreman is gonna have
to play a ton and I actually think that
Deontay Foreman can still play I know
he's been a healthy scratch the last few
weeks but he's not like totally dead to
have a big game here so I would wait if
Roshan Johnson's out I would go Foreman
if ran Johnson's in I might go Madison
but yeah what do you think on that one
Leoni yeah I think on Madison on this
one either way definitely if if Roshan
Johnson's out on Madison if he's out
it's you know it's for sure tougher and
closer as you said they're going
different directions but I think Madison
still might get more high value touches
than than Foreman would you know more
targets more goal line carries
Minnesota's the better team they've got
the higher team total they favored in
this one so um that's the way that's the
way I'm looking at it even though you do
feel like it's the falling knife sort of
thing with Madison right now for sure
all right appreciate all the questions
from all of you appreciate you all
hanging out here today for as part of
the week
six fy's football show presented on
bleach report presented by State
Farm as always if you're interested in
more of myself and Leone's work you can
head to establish the run.com we also
have a lot of free content on our
YouTube channel and on our iTunes feed
you can just search establish run you
should be able to find that on either of
those platforms of course be sure you're
following our friends at Bleacher Report
on all of their social platforms as well
for all the good people at bleacher
report for Leone for all the good people
at State Farm I am Adam good luck this
weekend